i do have to ask you so i interviewed
nessa
barrett who i'm sure you know she i
think she's
great um and she was very
candid and also got really like
emotional and upset because people
accused her of copying you
yeah did you see that and did you have a
response
yeah it went down i think it's really
sad when
um people just find a way to bring
others down
i deal with it myself people say that i
copy people people say nasa copies
me people say it's just this never
ending like who really was the first to
do
anything you know all collaboration from
people
who came along before us and i just
think that we as
artists and musicians and people who
create things are
we're trying to inspire at least i am
and so i spoke to nessa she's the
sweetest person and i
never in a million years was like i just
hate when people pin people against each
other like there's like weird drama and
i'm like it's not like that i think
she's
so incredible and such a sweetheart and
i wish her nothing but the absolute best
in the entire world
and it doesn't matter at the end of the
day if she pulled inspiration from my
video or not
i'm happy if she did because that to me
is that's a compliment and that's a form
of flattery and i don't
want to live in a world that like art is
so gate kept and it's like
we can't like no like if it inspires
somebody great that's my
whole entire goal and why i create music
and why i create art is to hopefully
inspire people so i don't know where
this sudden
like you want to be this person or
you're copying this person came from
where it's like no we all want to be our
own people we just maybe it's like are
inspired by x y and z and i just don't
know why that's always kind of been like
this
problem i find it frustrating and i do
think
i don't think i've ever actually done
this but you think the media tends to do
it sometimes and i saw that you actually
responded
did someone say that you were copying
ariana grande
did i see that right well people say
that about me like people say a lot of
stuff
i could people say everything about me
but yeah i know people say oh she copies
ariana and i'm like i've been an ariana
fan since i was
so young like i don't know why like
there i'll see tick tocks where i'll see
videos of girls you know doing their
hair like her
making a video like her and it's like oh
my god you killed this and then i like
do my hair
remotely yeah and they're like you cut
wannabe and i'm like
why can't i just like her hair and like
also
again like where who really started
anything like we're all just people
and we all are just like doing our thing
and i think that there's nothing wrong
with being inspired by somebody i look
up to ariana
so much and she's one of my idols i
think she's so strong and beautiful
and i don't know why me being inspired
by her in some way
would ever be an issue so yeah i did um
speak about that recently and just kind
of was like yeah it makes me sad because
i don't think
people should be pinning women against
each other we should be lifting each
other up and
um inspiring one another a thousand
percent
and i think that was like very
eloquently
said and hopefully you don't have to
deal with that anymore is the performing
though getting you more excited about
this debut album yeah definitely
i i just want to perform it like i love
performing and i love touring and
singing and dancing and just like that's
always what i've loved first is
performing so i hope that
we end up able to do all of that but
yeah i'm so excited for my album to come
out
it's called life support right
why why are you calling it life support
um lifesport felt like the perfect title
when i was making it
because it really was such a lifeline
for me and it was really like one of the
only reasons i got out of bed in the
morning was to go make
um not the only reason was to go make
this album and it was like my motivation
and i thank it
for actually like keeping me alive in a
lot of ways and i felt like i was
falling into a really
dark um heavy
depression and i was able to kind of
work through it
with making this album it was very
therapeutic for me and it was
my outlet and i'm just really really
grateful for it